welcome back to another episode of the
iced coffee hour and today we got a
really interesting episode because uh
we're gonna be doing a few things one I
got a gift for you jack oh something we
have to talk about it's a bit of an
issue but uh I did get you something an
issue yeah two we have to talk about the
uh Macy proposal because we never
followed up with it we talked about it
before we never talked about that exact
day and lastly we have to finish off
with uh responding to some of the hate
comments uh we had somebody screenshot a
whole bunch of them we have no idea what
they say but I see every now and then we
get a few nasty ones they've been brutal
they've been really bad so uh we're
gonna be reacting to them so first Jack
uh let's talk about this you desperately
need a haircut it's really bad you
really sound like my mom no but it's
true from your guys's perspective it may
be true but I'm not trying to appeal to
you guys okay now I you know I'm trying
to appeal to like 23 old women and I
think that this haircut is a hit by the
way speaking of appealing to 23 year old
women on the last podcast did you see
the highly voted comment of some girl
who wanted to take Jack on a date like
really yeah highly voted comments yeah
yeah yeah the top comment the top
comment and got like 300 up votes oh wow
yeah really Rose oh I liked it I'm 22
started my own business barely finished
College where could I send to go on a
date with Jack let's film the first date
too see come on really
oh so anyway yeah I don't want to get
too off topic so we got that uh but Jack
needs a haircut agreed Kayla will
probably agree with me I think it's
Charming it makes me stand out I'm very
unique you know with this haircut and I
think it's a net positive although yes
you could argue I do look like a slob
you know I look like I'm unkempt but
unkempt I can reassure you I am kempt
and I think it's a you know it's a
unique look you got the trucker hat on
and it looks like a mullet so now you're
a trucker hat mullet guy look at you
mullet man yeah that sounds pretty good
mullet guy oh well a trucker hat mullet
guy is pretty cool too I think so oh and
you know molds are actually making
comeback so you guys your hairstyles
actually might be oh Jack I got you a
little something oh thank you because
you refuse to get a haircut we have to
make some improvement trimmers so uh
yeah well what is it
foreign
oh my God
I love this holy cow okay it says the
man the myth the legend uh I think this
is perfect for me this is amazing yeah
he knows you like trucker hats yes yeah
oh because yeah you used to wear these
like oh my God I like it though that's
the thing and it fits I think I think
it's like this I need to grow up my
mullet longer it only makes sense what
was interesting is that you used to wear
like a like a baseball cap yeah this
orange baseball cap all the time yeah
and then out of a sudden all of a sudden
you get this uh trucker out of nowhere
and Graham and I noticed ever since you
got that hat that's the only hat that
you wear why is the trucker had such big
talk man you know it's a good hat I like
the Hat I made it at my cousin's Bar
Mitzvah to tell you the truth that's
what I did and I just like the Hat I
think it looks nice you know what that
hat reminds me of uh of Roman Atwood do
you guys see he recently started a
podcast yeah yeah yeah and I I
so there's a more competition out there
I've noticed that everybody is getting
into podcasts yeah and uh you know I
don't want to say we were early but
honestly we were kind of late yeah we
were late yeah
it's like those things where when
everybody's like well if I had just
started YouTube then you know and then
like it keeps growing keeps growing so I
think it started at a good time but yeah
everybody's starting a podcast and what
I said last episode with Daniel Mack
turned out to be very true I said people
listen to us when they're driving or
when they're at the gym and we got so
many comments of people saying exactly
what they were doing while they were
listening to the podcast and like
probably 40 of them were gym and then
like 45 were driving yeah so it's true
it holds true so if you're at the gym or
you're driving down below yeah there's
going to be a lot of podcasts I think
because uh it's it's sustainable in a
way that you can't just keep making
these like over-the-top videos all the
time for a podcast it's sitting in just
half having a conversation and I think
more people are catching on to that it's
also very genuine I mean we shared that
you were engaged on here before you
mentioned anything yeah anywhere else
like yeah my parents even found out from
the podcast
I'm kidding okay it sounded like a like
something grandpa when did you tell your
parents because I remember when we spoke
about it on the podcast for the first
time yeah you said you had not told them
yet yeah it was a few days before a few
days before is it yeah about a few days
five days before well people commented
that Jack was upset that I didn't
propose to Jack I saw that watching that
clip back with that comment it looks
like you were like too excited that he
was proposing to you and then that you
were sad that it was in church I just
thought it was a big deal to be honest I
thought it was a really big deal and I
was shocked because I knew that you were
planning on doing it this year but it
just I feel like it came by so quickly
it did so both lies for those that want
to know the proposal went very smoothly
Graham did a great job Macy said yes so
and we couldn't see a single thing I
don't know so we were all talking in the
last podcast Alex had mentioned you got
to get a picture of it so that way like
you get the moment and I thought great
ideas so I told Alex and Jack that could
go down to the uh the Santa Monica Pier
without the telephoto lens and like try
to get us at the top of the ferris wheel
and so I tried so hard to make sure that
we were like I tell you exactly which
cart we're in we were coming yeah we got
you yeah which car you were in we we
were like we had this super long loan so
we were able to see but the problem was
that the way that the angle was like it
was like uh initially when you and Macy
were like sitting across from each other
we could see you guys but then Macy did
the unexpected guys she went over to
Graham's side I don't know and then we
lost sight of everything and then Jack
and I rushed over to go meet Graham at
the bottom of the ferris wheel after
because we're like oh we'll take some
pictures like by the arcade you know
we're at the at this uh you know little
fair at the pier and uh Graham just
texted me yeah we're heading to the
restaurant I cannot believe you left
without
[Music]
we were a little bit further out on the
pier and we were trying to get some
beautiful photos and videos for our
lovely future groom Graham and you came
off the ferris wheel and immediately
left you like you booked you shared your
GPS
you were like halfway up the pier like
right after you got off we hung out
afterwards we were over and celebrating
we hung out afterwards we were at the
bottom for a little bit maybe a few
minutes and like I looked around didn't
see you guys I didn't know it was it
would ruin the surprise if you guys like
show up because we were meeting your
family afterwards we're gonna see you
guys like I know but you've seen your
family so maybe she's like oh also I
think you guys ran a little late so
maybe her family was also yeah I assume
that you know yeah I gotta get up there
but yeah so walk us through now that
you've done it yeah how did it feel that
day how did it feel you know going
through it were you nervous I was
nervous leaving it leading up to I
honestly thought there's nothing to be
nervous about it's like why why would it
be nervous I knew the answer was going
to be a yes I knew she'd be very excited
and I knew it was coming so I'd like I
didn't have those nerves except the day
of just just because I was only nervous
because I didn't want anything to go
wrong
so I was really scared that like what if
we go down to the pier and uh the ferris
wheel isn't going or like it's out of
order then what do I do what if we go
down the pier and like we run into you
guys then it's going to be obvious or as
we were walking down to the pier her
parents were at the restaurant and it
was across the street so I was like
diverting her attend to be like look at
the ocean over there look at this
building what do you think this so I was
like just because I so afraid she'd look
over and like see her family say what
are they doing there so all the things
that could go wrong that's what I was
nervous about but it was good and then
and then on the ferris wheel I wanted it
to stop at the top and it kept going
around and we weren't stopping at the
time like what if this is the one time
it doesn't stop at the top and like we
have to go on again like would that be
too obvious so I didn't get the very top
but I got like the notch to the top and
uh yeah it was good did you cry no no
did she cry she she teared she did a few
tears yeah I was gonna say I forgot to
ask she did a thumbnail face
but in real life but in real life yeah
yeah well I gotta say man we're happy
for you I I can't believe it and uh I
think everybody else was wondering do
you know when the wedding's gonna be
it's gonna be a ways off just because
we're both busy we don't have to think
about it like right now but yeah
big wedding small wedding expensive
wedding oh gosh for your uh friends to
come out there type planning I'm not a
I'm not a big wedding person so like I
would if if to me I mean just like a few
people but I don't know it's it's it's
up to her I'll let her make the decision
on that well Kelsey went to go look at
uh wedding dresses today oh yeah yeah I
told her not to get too excited why the
cost yeah I don't want she told me how
much one would cost she she told me you
know she'd we'd rather not say yet that
either that's what you told me so how
much do you think is appropriate to
spend on a wedding dress Max
this is like you find a dress that you
absolutely love you have to have it
thousand bucks Max okay how much do they
usually cost I don't know like I there's
boutique stores but there's also like
online you can also actually rent
wedding dresses because the thing is a
lot of people will spend thousands of
dollars on this dress and then keep it
in their closet for who knows how long
and yeah it's cool if you want to have
it but sometimes you can rent like a
really expensive dress for like a couple
hundred bucks and you don't have
something sitting in your closet what if
you made the wedding dress Boom YouTube
video boom it's also sentimental boom
it's also cheap one is your time yeah
it's the time you know how much time
that would take
like I'm not I don't sew day to day so
I'm not like you could just get get a
bed sheet some confetti go buy some
potatoes some toilet paper from the sack
potatoes toilet paper wedding dress but
just don't get it wet that's viral
content right there yeah right well how
much do you guys think is appropriate to
spend on a wedding I have no family
preference yeah I have no idea I think
yeah like I said I think that's like the
tippy top but there I know she told me
that there were wedding dresses there
that caught I think the range at that
particular store was between like one
and a half and eight thousand so eight
thousand dollars the bottom of the range
was already too expensive well there's
the cheapest one there is over a bunch
of clearance oh yeah and then you know
you can The Returned items now what
about pre-owned yeah pre-owned I I'm
okay with that actually I think that's a
great way like to get a wedding dress
yeah what if you resold it you just got
a super nice one more for the wedding
which returned it like how about at that
point you're better off well no you're
that's the ethical thing yeah you should
rent it yeah Jack
I've never worn something from a store
and then returned it no you've done that
no no God no you probably
you know what at least you're honest
about it what do you think it was uh
jackets so h m had a very liberal return
policy them too yeah you could have
bought it there's no probably Stephanie
no so sometimes what I do is I watch
even still he knows he's still to this
day I still never take the tags off
clothing so on a lot of my jackets I
still have the tag in there and so
sometimes I'll wear the jacket out and
then never wear it again after a month
I'm like I've yet to wear this thing
again I'm not gonna wear it again and
return it but even now it's like if you
drive to h m you know that whole ordeal
is going to take an hour for what now
this is years ago I haven't done this in
a long time oh yeah
yeah no no this is recent long time yeah
I have Alex return it no Alex shows up
this jacket doesn't fit me it's the
wrong size my mom bought this for me as
a Christmas present and it just I think
she she miscalculated myself Jack it's
all of his clothes for free so it's not
gonna matter that is
true
[Music]
I'm not gonna say that's entirely true
but that's mostly true yes they're all
hand-me-downs so where do you get your
clothes from yeah do you guys want to
know the truth is it your mom yeah my
mom gets me most my clothes to be honest
she got me this shirt these shorts right
actually these shorts I got I feel like
your mom's like a 90s skater kid too my
mom was a 90s skater kid yeah just buy
like The zj's Boarding House sort of
like you know the surf attire and like
yeah the trucker hat or whatever I gotta
say guys you know I usually don't share
this stuff willingly but in this case I
think it's kind of funny it makes for a
good story but I went on a date uh
probably five days ago
yeah so it's we went to Dave and
Buster's and I showed up and I thought I
looked really good like I'm not gonna
lie I thought my outfit was nice I
thought she was gonna be like really
pleased with it after Dave and Buster's
we went back to my house to go in the
hot tub and I was like going in my my
room or whatever to like pick out like
board shorts for the for the hot tub and
she followed me into the closet and she
saw that I had very few clothes and then
she said just out of nowhere I didn't
like instigate it she just said that
explains it and I was like what are you
talking about yeah what are you talking
about it's his first date yes okay and
she said she said oh I just you know I
noticed like the clothes you were
wearing uh at David Buster's and I was
like what are you trying to say and
she's like oh it's just you know like
questionable Style
can you believe it I could believe it
Jack well what were you wearing yeah um
I was wearing a navy shirt some Navy
pants shirt what t-shirt yeah a t-shirt
yeah okay Navy t-shirt it's got like a
little design right here okay Navy pants
and then brown shoes no
I bet the pants were probably a bit
baggy I like the I like the brown shoes
with the Navy pants yes I'm a fan of the
brown and navy like suit combination but
I think the navy shirt overdoes it do
you wear the hat yeah yeah yeah okay so
that's actually a good point she said
the main thing she said I don't know why
you wore a hat so dude I'm telling you
right now if you cut your hair I'm not
even joking
you would probably look 10 times the
thing is people assume that you're
balding because you wear the hat so
often
sometimes I think you have to take
certain things that we know we're not
good at and just accept the fact we're
not good at them and let other people
help us for you I would venture to say
it's style yeah I think for me as well
but you know wow but Alex could get away
with the pineapples on his shirt listen
man why can he get away is the bar just
lower for Alex yeah what's wrong with
that it's not that crazy this is Alex's
style and it works but it works it works
as like a funny sort of like Whimsical
t-shirt by the way I wanted to ask how's
the weight loss coming could you explain
what's going on did we did we talk about
we haven't spoken about this yet no you
want to say what's going on sure so I
you know I happen to notice that Alex
May struggle with his weight a little
bit so you happen to notice what is that
supposed to mean
are you explain it
I'm just kidding go ahead um I figured
out I would like to help a friend uh and
I think it could also be an inspiring
story since we've discussed it on the
podcast a few times and you know for
Alex it's not only it's like also a
mental thing as well you know and I
think that overcoming that mental
barrier as well as being a healthier
individual I think could be a really
good piece of content and also something
that I would love to do for my friend uh
on a personal level so what we decided
to do was try to get Alex to lose some
weight and we are on what just over two
weeks now I think so yeah yeah we're
just over two weeks are we yeah yeah
just almost two weeks I think oh I think
on Wednesday yeah on Wednesdays two
weeks you know I'm taking a lot of
advice from tons of people that know a
lot about nutrition and dieting and
exercising and stuff like that
um the main thing that we're just trying
to focus on is eating just good healthy
hearty foods and that's pretty much it
and no snacking yeah some text so every
day Jack text me like uh close to lunch
time and he's just like hey what are you
having to eat and so every time I make
food I just uh I take a picture and I
send it over to Jack or if I like him in
a rush I'll just tell Jack hey I had
this for lunch and um and I do that for
like my lunch and my dinner and uh we
also do weigh-ins and I go grocery
shopping with Jack and so far so good so
Jack uh I lost how much so far you've
lost you lost 6.6 pounds in 11 days now
granted I know that may sound unhealthy
the speed at which you lost weight but
then again once you start dieting and
cutting down on those the fatty foods
and the snacking Foods you have less
sodium in your body which soaks up less
water so a lot of that was water weight
and I would say probably let's say on
two pounds or so maybe three pounds of
fat and we're also trying to find like
that sweet spot so we dialed it up a
little bit on the on the calories a
little bit so
um but so far so good the first week uh
was was pretty hard yeah yeah I mean it
was a huge change right yeah and um we
talk about this on or off or sorry we
talk about this off the podcast a lot
more
um just because you guys are my friends
and so sometimes you guys may not hear
like the entirety of the conversations I
told Jack having I've never had anybody
try to like hold me like accountable and
it's been a very different experience
and one thing Graham told me he's like
takes 21 days to build to have it and
it's getting easier every day that's
good I mean you're doing great I'm
eating great food yeah you can throw
some pictures of the food I've been
making yeah yeah sometimes it's like you
know really lean sometimes it's a little
bit like uh Comfort meals but it's not
like crazy you know it's very different
than what I was eating right because I
think most of the calories that I was
intaking were from snacking and so we
kind of changed now if I'm really hungry
I I'll grab like a pinch of grapes or
something now what about exercise so I'm
looking to reintroduce or introduce more
exercise
um as well so
um I think I had this conversation I'm
not sure if both of you but
um I had lost weight in the past and one
of the good exercises that I found for
myself was swimming just because it's
very low impact but it's very high
cardio and um so
I think I'm probably gonna start doing
that I'm gonna say probably start with
two times a week probably next week or
this week what not this week I could do
that too the main idea that I had in
mind when you you know with your plan of
losing weight was I didn't want to
introduce too many things right in the
beginning because I didn't want you to
hate it so as long as like you're eating
clean you're gonna lose weight pretty
dang fast at your current weight and
that was the plan until you got to maybe
maybe you lost like you know 40 40 50
pounds and then we could introduce
exercising and stuff like that once you
got used to that and built up that habit
of eating clean no more unhealthy
snacking and stuff like that well I
could start as like resistance walking
through the pool yeah I mean that and
then you build up and like I remember
when I first ever swam I couldn't even
swim a lap like at all and it took me
several weeks to be able to do it I
don't know if I can now because it's
been two and a half years since I swam
yeah so
I agree I gotta say I'm honestly really
impressed and I definitely this probably
doesn't help my case at all but I I
definitely had some like pre-judgments
about like when I first wanted to to
diet you I thought that because the
first thing I did was I went over to his
house and we went through his entire
pantry and I removed all the unhealthy
food and I thought that when I was doing
that you'd be like no I want that no I
want that no I want that still but
you're very open to it and you're
optimistic which is one of my favorite
Parts you're not complaining all the
time you're not saying oh I wish that I
had more sweets or I wish I didn't have
to do this you're super like proactive
about it I don't have to constantly be
checking on you you're pretty like
self-sufficient on it it's the texting
me like holding me account like when you
text me in the morning it like reaffirms
like oh today I'm going to be
accountable yeah and I told Jack the
other day I was like Jack I really want
some pizza and like so we but we went
out to that event and I ate some like
food that was off my thing so I'm gonna
win before I got pizza but uh like yeah
Jack and I have had Burgers together we
if we go to an event we it out and it's
just like we kind of account for it and
it's like there's nothing wrong with
eating unhealthy food every once in a
while the only thing is the snacking and
if you do that like all of the time like
every day yeah like I want to take the
exact snack every day yeah and the thing
is when you snacked the issue is you
would eat really calorie dense things
such as a bag of potato chips like a big
bag and you'd eat like probably 2 000
calories in one sitting and not even
know it yeah but now it's like you know
you're very like structured with your
diet and I think the best way to
introduce like a healthy eating habit is
to introduce like normal eating habits
we're like sure if you go to an event
you have some pizza or if you want pizza
you can order pizza and I think that's
the important part for me too because I
don't I told Jack I could never be
like you like you eat so clean like I
don't think that could ever be me but
you have to remember like to get to the
weight that I am I've probably been
eating like unhealthy like to what a
normal person would consider extremely
unhealthy for so long I think that going
back to like a diet of like normalcy and
having moderation with foods that are
higher in calories is is good and that's
probably like the life that I would want
to live
um but who knows you never know because
maybe I'll see some gains and I'll be
like
this is the way but my mindset is that
right now so we'll see I'm just very
open to
everything and I really appreciate you
you know helping me so far so good and
Graham's been supportive to just uh like
emotionally on the side so that's good
yeah you're killing it so I honestly to
be completely fair and honest I have no
idea what I'm doing but I figure
anything that we do do where it means
that you eat cleaner foods you eat
healthier foods it's just a step just
for liability reasons I have nothing to
do with this guys I'm just I just went
for the record right you agree Jack like
this is nothing to do this is why you
were texting me advice like the other
day you were like this is advice this is
Health advice directly from Graham
Stefan no Graham's just there as a
friend to be supportive yeah
no liability Jack definitely tells me
what to do yeah yeah we'll see about
that but you've been doing great and
we're gonna be continuing to document
this entire Journey really exciting you
know what's cool uh Jack sent me this
earlier that um who is it Mike Malak and
Jeff from Jeff's Barber Shop or uh
mentioned me in the podcast this morning
wait what yeah yeah I made a video on uh
Mike Malak buying a property with an nft
on the second Channel The Graham Stefan
show go and subscribe to that but I made
a video talking about that and uh Mike
and Jeff watched the video and sometimes
it for me I forget like how many people
see these videos and so I think
sometimes if I'm just joking around or
making light-hearted humor I forget
sometimes that there's like a real
person behind there who's two could be
taking these literally or could be
taking it the wrong way and uh took it
the wrong way I think Mike saw parts of
the video that could have potentially
been hurtful and not like a malicious
way necessarily but maybe not the nicest
of ways and usually on that channel I
try my best I'm sarcastic and it's it's
all satin not all satire but no I didn't
say anything but you know I said uh you
know I made jokes that were probably at
Mike's expense like I said you know it's
the peak of the market but it goes to
show you there's always going to be a
mic who's buying because she's buying I
mean it was I like it was meant in a
light-hearted way not to be taken too
seriously but I also I think lose track
when you're like behind a computer
screen looking at the numbers that like
that is a person you're talking about
and uh like you know I have nothing
against Mike or anything and a lot of it
is just meant purely for comedy but I
think comedy at the expense of someone
else I'm realizing that you know the
more I have to do the mark on this one I
don't think so and he overall said that
the video was was uh you know
it wasn't a bad video and a lot of it
was was accurate but also that I didn't
know the entire situation and I and I
even said that in the video I tried to
estimate what his income was based on
how much he put down and he explained
that he put down more because it gave
him a lower interest rate which is true
um so there were I I had to stretch and
make some assumptions just uh just for
the purposes of the video and supplying
information so I definitely went out and
limb there but the thing is he could be
making five million a year and it makes
no difference whatsoever if he buys a
property for four if it's worth three
next year if it's worth fighting it's
like it doesn't matter and I think at
those income levels it's like you're
talking over the equivalent of like what
a normal person would be like a few
hundred dollars so like for him it
doesn't make a difference so how much do
you think Mike is making in this video
because I will say before you say the
number
Graham has given us estimates for of a
lot of people before we've met them yeah
and then people confirm and they're
pretty damn close yeah I will say you
have a pretty good idea I'm not saying
it's accurate now Adam 22 is the biggest
shock for me I didn't know he was making
that much yeah and Anna came in under
fourth but Mike Malak I said that for
him to afford his mortgage he had to be
netting after expenses 720 000 a year
that that's the bare minimum so I kind
of assumed that if he had to put more
money down he was hitting that limit
which meant that he was making way more
money but since he's his own boss he's
probably deducting a lot of expenses so
I said he's probably making about 1.2 so
a hundred thousand dollars a month plus
she's got expenses so he's netting you
know 720 to 800 000 a year he didn't
confirm or deny that amount nor would I
expect him to be like here's how much I
make but I could I would say like I
wouldn't be surprised if he's making
five million a year but I would say it
minimum Mom it's got to be the 720 at
minimum like that's what he would have
to do to qualify for that yeah because
there may be other deals that are behind
the scenes that we have no problem
probably yeah sometimes when you're in
that circle of people you get
opportunity I mean you get opportunities
presented to you that
you know yeah it's not worth making a
whole video on but you're invested in
other things yeah so anyway but but
sometimes you see those videos and I
feel bad just because it's like I never
want to make anyone feel bad and my my
intention is never to put anyone down so
and sometimes you do get caught up in in
that moment of just like that's it's
funny it's for comedy but then you
forget it's like well you know that is a
person on the other end who's who's
seeing this and I I've definitely gotten
a lot more careful of of what I said on
that channel I reacted to ads before and
that was like an old fun thing as it
react to the ads and
um at the end like I just felt bad
afterwards because some of the stuff
like I'm poking fun at it but but like
that's their business and whether or not
I agree with it not all malicious
but you know some of it a little a
little sketchy but I will say I like
those I like that video people do but uh
I just feel bad about it even though
people like it
so anyway what do you think Jack
I think you know with the Graham Stefan
show you assume responsibility when you
say certain things about other people
and I know just with like media in
general it's easier to throw accusations
and to like point fingers uh especially
considering the fact that usually the
Creator is never like held to a certain
standard when they probably should be
you know what I mean creators get let
off for saying some bad things about
other people I think as a general you
specifically you're pretty fair but I
also think that with the responsibility
of having that channel that's definitely
something that you should consider and
knowing you I don't think that you ever
really cross that line but it seems like
you have a pretty good perspective on I
wouldn't be too worried about it yeah I
think it's I think it's about getting
close to that line but never Crossing it
um because I never want to be in a
position where I say something truly
negative about someone where if they saw
me somewhere they would be upset
um and I would expect that all of it
would be kind of light-hearted but I did
see that and I felt bad so if Mike is
watching this what do you have to say uh
none of it was meant to be like too
serious a lot of it's just lighthearted
humor but but uh if if anything I said
was was taken the wrong way I apologize
for it because it's never my intention
to make anyone feel bad and you know I
do make stretches and assumptions in
that video just for the purposes of
filling in some of the numbers but uh
definitely I I didn't get all of it
right I'm sure so if there's anything
that I could correct I'm always open to
that have you dm'd Mike before have you
guys spoke yeah uh so I met him in 2020
actually with you briefly when we picked
up the Pokemon card yeah yeah yeah um
the Pokemon card the local box breaks I
met him briefly and then after that he
had mentioned me in one of the impulsive
podcasts uh it's like the finance guy or
something like that and so I sent him a
message saying uh thank you for the kind
words uh if you would ever like to uh do
a collab or like I'd love to have you on
my channel just anything like that I'm
open now it never showed red or anything
like that so I don't know if he got it
but I did send him a message make me
like next podcast guess let's go yeah I
would love it yeah absolutely love them
yeah I love that yeah if anyone knows
Mike malach and you want to shoot him a
text and be like hey if you're in Las
Vegas Graham Stefan would love to host
you do whatever your dinner
yeah we take you out for steak at herbs
and Rye like a nice steak nice steak
place uh make you feel welcome so how
about this uh we got hate comments yes
we have some hate comments we have to
get back to all right now depending on
the tone of these hate comments I'm
gonna try to take them to heart and see
you know if these are really good
criticisms that you know something that
we can work on so the first hate comment
and again guys we did not pick these we
had somebody else pick these so we have
never seen these before correct I really
ain't trying to see a morbidly obese guy
to struggle to ask the most basic
questions Jack I don't know why they
hate you so much why did you write that
Jack I'm sorry gosh no so I think
they're talking about me what I don't
know what do you guys think I mean I try
to ask
questions that I feel like the audience
would like to know you know and that's
why I bring up stuff like when Graham
was talking about the ring I was like
that's a pretty small ring familiar not
because I think that but just like I'm
trying to think what would the audience
think in my my yes and also when
introducing podcast guests I mean I do
the same thing I try to think like okay
imagine I'm a new viewer and I've never
seen this I really try to go from that
angle I am obese but we're trying to
work that's I don't think that's a
comment to take to heart I don't think
so yeah I know yeah the morbidly obesity
just seems to be like the poking stick
yeah the real thing seems to be the
basic question but I would agree with
the basic question I mean you have to
all right Jack has been looking sloppy
get a haircut okay well oh I just
glanced over and I saw that it was
written by my assistant so JJ uh we have
a serious talk wait was it actually yeah
all right all right jack you don't buy
and hold with margin silly boy
[Laughter]
it is good advice yeah
what do you got yeah okay you know what
the silly boy was just you know that was
unnecessary but you know he's he's
probably he is right all right I like
how we're so analytical well this part
was yeah yeah we should take them all
take them all seriously you're right I
won't do it again I stopped watching
your videos because they are all Buy and
Hold index funds yeah I think Beyond a
certain point it does become repetitive
I mean I'm never gonna say anything
different so if you're expecting me one
video to say like hey guys go all in
Tesla and then short this I'm never
gonna say that but you know what I think
long term that'll come out ahead so I'm
gonna stick with it one thing I'll say
is you've been very consistent with your
I'm not gonna deviation for that yeah
when you click bait so much you have to
clarify it when it's not click bait did
we did we do like we do a lot of
clickbaits
one oh margin hold oh Margin Call wow so
yeah I mean I agree I mean for sure I
think we stretch the truth on the titles
but the titles do have a direct
connection with exactly what we talk
about in the the video so it's never
like taking completely like like just
wrong information and putting it in the
title but usually it is what we talk
about and then maybe exaggerate it a
little bit we don't exaggerate numbers
but we can exaggerate where you know
where we can yeah I actually thought the
not clickbait was catchier just like
just as a title I would be more likely
to click on a title this is not
clickbait that from my perspective it's
just like what would people be likely to
click on it that's just my strategy yeah
yeah so I wouldn't say yeah Graham is
127 pounds homeboy is Tiny I haven't
been that small since I was like 19 like
I wish homeboy is tired but he said I
wish so he wishes he could be smaller
maybe you know there so that could be
not a little left yeah that could be a
compliment maybe they'd be like I wish I
could weigh 127 so I'll take that as a
compliment that could be a nice comment
well what do you say to people who say
that you're small it just it is what it
is
the sky is blue I mean
no offense but Graham is wrong AF on
Tesla stock and Elon you can tell he's
an s p investor mainly doesn't know much
about the individual stocks oh that's
probably when I said the Tesla stock was
overvalued you know what I I think what
what gets me is the amount of hype and
excitement around the stock
um and all the potential around it like
Elon Musk could come up with these
robots and self-driving and all these
different things
um I've yet to see a lot of it come to
fruition and I worry that the hype and
excitement has gotten ahead of itself a
little bit too much but I will fully
admit I've been wrong in the past I've
been wrong so far about Tesla stock
except when I sold at a thousand dollars
to buy the car so far but that could be
that's probably luck Grandma's been
trying to justify his lifestyle this
entire episode I've been watching Graham
for a very long time and I like the guy
but I do agree with Jack and Tech lead
Graham should live a little bit more I'm
not saying he needs to spend any more
money or stop YouTube or the podcast but
life experience would really help him
grow all these Ventures as well as
refining his perspective I don't
disagree with that I think I need some
more perspective I agree what do you
mean by perspective seeing more things
being exposed to more I think but I
think everybody could benefit that's
true yeah but I think yeah me especially
I could probably I think yeah he says
things with very much tunnel vision yeah
I do so I could benefit from that it's
interesting to hear how detached from
reality gram is when it comes to how
materialistic he actually is making
money two thousand dollar loan from
grandma brought that could save
someone's life and how much 250 000
could actually do well Tech lead is
detached from what is like to try and
become wealthy outside of school
programmer doctor lawyer Etc very cool
perspective to hear as a thousand air so
I mean where do we start on this one uh
making my two thousand dollar loan from
Grandma so let me uh let me explain what
is that I don't remember so when I was
buying property in 2011 2012
um I had basically sunk all my money and
I sold my car to finish and and buy
these properties and renovate them and
there was a point where I I had a tenant
who was moving into a property and was
going to pay me the rent and all that uh
and I needed to pay the contractor and
this is before like I had a credit card
or anything like that and I knew there
was a two-week gap between when I was
having rent coming in and when I had to
pay the contractor and my grandma lent
me two thousand dollars so that I could
pay the contractor uh as basically like
a bridge in between the times that that
happened and I got the rent so what's
the total amount of out of pocket that
you were at the time like invested in
this house renovating because I'm sure
probably a drop in the bucket like 200
Grand something like that 250. yeah well
yeah give or take probably 250. I mean
it was it was everything I had saved up
for four years so I and I sold the car
to pay for the triplex
um so yeah but I also had some real
estate deals that were coming in and
sometimes it's like you have to wait a
few weeks to get paid on those so uh
that was the two thousand dollars I get
that not everybody's in a position to
you know borrow two thousand dollars
from your grandma I certainly wasn't but
I think that there's nothing wrong with
using the resources that that you have
right and plus if your grandma didn't
let you borrow two thousand dollars
somebody yeah or you would have paid
interest to someone yeah it's not a big
uh yeah I mean it would have gotten done
regardless but uh my first choice would
have been to go to my grandma and I paid
her right back I feel like Jack is
talking himself out of a job with graham
he's just Outsourcing all of his work to
other people for cheaper why wouldn't
Graham just do it himself you know why
wouldn't I jack because that takes a lot
of upfront capital
okay so my question was why wouldn't
Graham just pay you a
salary to manage people a salary to
management yeah like I could just pay
you a set amount and you manage because
I'm not an employee we'll make you an
employee I'd prefer not to be an
employee I think we'll find somebody
else to manage the people okay
there's nothing that's stopping you from
doing that I mean like as far as no I'm
just trying to play Devil's I mean 85 of
my incomes from the ice coffee hour so
if we're talking about the the 15 on the
side of like you know like the second
chain all the random stuff here and
there
actually it's probably ten percent the
other stuff so it's not like it's you
know what I mean yeah I mean my thought
is that uh as long as the work is better
or the same I'm okay with it yeah yeah
as long as you're okay by Outsource the
main Channel well the main channel is
something that even Outsourcing to begin
with no no not on the main channel the
main Channel I'm so particular about
better if you show me a video Alex and
we review it and it is better and I and
I look at this video and I say Alex did
you just spend a whole day on this thing
how long did this take you to do how did
you do it like this and it's that good
I'd be open to it what if it's the same
probably not it would have to be better
like when Jack did it it was better and
I told Jack you could try it once yeah
and it has to be really good and I
didn't even know it was better and I
thought Jack was just spending more time
on the videos as far as camera angles go
I personally think there should just be
one camera slash angle it would be much
more podcast like in my opinion just
seeing everyone in one shot versus
having multiple angles and going back
and forth between all of them most
podcasts out here follow the one camera
Rule and that's what I think this
podcast needs to go now you gotta switch
Yeah you got to switch camera angles
yeah helps retention every big podcast
on it also has different camera angles
I'd like more of Alex less of Jack LOL
what does Jackie even do anymore you
know what I agree with this one do you
what'd you do today Jack what did I do
today hung out went in the pool drank
some Pepsi
really no I think
well not the Pepsi did I film The Pool I
don't remember if I went in the pool
what do you say to the people though who
say less Jack I think that's fine
everyone's gonna have their own opinion
and I don't think that there's anything
that I can say that would change their
mind if they're already in the thought
of less Jack so there's so many project
people though so it's okay I'm yeah I
really appreciate the people that are
pro Jack I feel like I kind of want to
read like a love comment now after
reading so many hate comments Graham
kind of killed this to family Vlog as
soon as he took over TBH the views don't
lie though I mean the data's there we
got the data's there I also uh happened
to change the the thumbnail and the Vlog
name and uh I only do it for 30 days but
the views don't lie yeah no for 30 days
we tripled views tripled Revenue
everything went up watch time went up
everything substantially increased for
this watch time went up because the
video the the length of the videos went
up
yeah but not but
no it wasn't daily postings three times
a week oh yeah anyway yeah Move Along
Alex is legit ungrateful LOL Graham
hired him as an employee why he acting
like he's owed anything I think there's
you guys both benefit from this
relationship you do and Graham does and
you guys are both very fortunate to have
the relationships
it's a good answer great Jack I think
answered that I like that Jack with
peace and love your ego has gotten way
too big keep telling you that I've
actually seen a few of those I'm not
gonna lie Jack ego stuff yeah no
obviously they're still the minority but
I definitely think I'm confident I just
think that you come across on the camera
more
than before right I feel like before you
were kind of still learning and kind of
in your shot I think I was shy I missed
the wide-eyed Jack like everything was
like oh my yeah well you saw Christine's
ring and you're like whoa like I missed
that those are like just the innocent
Uranus yeah
oh sorry it forced to buy Rolex at a
really good deal it was a good deal yeah
from Federico talks watches link Down
Below in the description or not just
search it and you just search it
Frederica tax watches we got someone
that pledged to our patreon during this
episode no wait no wait wait just now
yeah literally 30 minutes are you
serious
he says I watch a lot of YouTube I never
thought I'd make a patreon for anyone
like why I can watch for free
thank you man yeah but I love your show
and the guests you bring on you guys are
the best keep it up that is really cool
yeah well let's not thank you so much I
we really appreciate it uh we should we
could be giving plugs out Yeah we
actually we got another one we have to
call right now oh so okay so let me
explain it this is a big deal we put up
a 500 a month option on patreon and we
thought we'd put this up there and then
uh we'd all host an event twice a year
in Las Vegas where we could have
everyone together and just hang out
dinners on us drinks on us or whatever
the festivities are on us but we'd come
for one night have a great time two
times a year 500 a month but a lot of
that we just reinvest back into the
night so we'd have like you know two
crazy times a year just good time but we
got someone who signed up on that and we
got another person that I think we
should call right now Graham likes the
idea of whenever people sign up for that
we give them a call if you do that it's
gonna get to a point where we can't call
everybody no certainly so you know what
yeah it's not promised but
but it's a baby a hundred percent but as
of now let's call him who so who is this
uh okay so this is enam Khan I'm always
curious like and also shout out to Nam
Khan and Rick Barkley you guys paid the
the VIP patreon tier so you get a verbal
shout out every episode
hey uh this is Graham it's Jack and Alex
calling you on the iced coffee hour I
wanted to call you and thank you so much
for the joining the patreon uh we put
that up there just not having any idea
what to expect on this uh and we're
we're so happy to have you join we'll
let you know in the Las Vegas event is
going to be but what made you what made
you do it I'm curious oh my god well
first of all I'm excited for Las Vegas
second of all I I guess I got so much
value out of your videos over the years
this was one of my ways I felt like I
could get back and also just building a
relationship with you guys I feel like
that'll just be really good so I'm
definitely excited thank you so much
I've seen you guys grow over the years
Jack especially you myself watching the
first podcast the other day and I was
like yo Jack is so different now
good job guys you guys are doing great
work thank you now quick question for
you
um do you think Jack should get a
haircut
I actually just voted on his Instagram I
was one of the few guys I said no but oh
no
one of the few one of the few don't ruin
it don't look at it yeah but we got it
thank you well anyway man thank you so
much uh I really appreciate anything you
need just reach out and you're cool if
we include this on the uh on the podcast
yeah yeah
thanks for reaching out oh my God I'm
like so Starstruck right now
thank you absolutely so thank you so
much uh this will air in a few days and
uh anything you want to shout out oh
yeah I want to shout out my YouTube
channel and I'm on investing and I just
wanted to say I love you Mom
all right well thank you so much man I
really appreciate it good luck on the
olive hunt all these people are so nice
I'm excited to meet them in here this is
cool so anyway guys if you are
interested as well the link is down
below in the description we don't know
how many people are gonna get but uh you
know I'd like to call yeah I think it's
fun and it's good to put uh put a voice
behind the name as well and we need to
end this with you looking on Instagram
to determine whether or not you're
getting a haircut see if people want me
to get a haircut
we know what we shouldn't be leaving
this up to the patreon members it's like
that's a patreon exclusive like decide
when jackets a haircut and they decide
as a community each tier has like a
number of votes yes that's so funny yes
what's the percentage wow 60 40. yeah
that's not that's not as drastic as I
had all right
57-43 so I think the majority has said
you need a haircut but not a drastic
haircut just enough for a chicken or a
trim yeah it's just a trim well thank
you guys so much for voting and if you
guys want to vote on more things where I
could change my own physical appearance
follow me check out my Instagram
yeah make sure to also get a free stock
Down Below in the description when you
sign up for public using the gram and
you can also add
Alex on Instagram yes yeah take it to
our VIP patreon members yeah and until
next time until next time